hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
hd tutorial and in this one i'll be
showing you guys how to link your
youtube and twitter accounts uh now you
guys obviously all know my youtube
account but if you are not following me
on twitter i'll go ahead and throw that
link in the description so you guys can
uh check that out and if you want to
follow me i guess you can kind of
so anyway if you guys uh haven't already
figured it out you can you can uh set up
youtube to tweet for you every time you
do a youtube action now you're going to
want to configure this so it doesn't get
too annoying for your followers so
here's how i did it uh just go to the
upload tab
and uh you can go ahead and under
underneath this it says auto share
options it might or might not be
expanded like this it says new just go
ahead and expand that and it'll say you
can add a service to google reader
facebook or twitter and i just chose
twitter
um so actions will be shared such as
uploading videos rating videos
favoriting videos etc but again i'll
show you how to configure this uh and
it'll just go ahead and send out a tweet
for you so uh i would show you an
example but i haven't uploaded a video
recently so i can't you know go right
back and find it
but
again it's really cool that it'll just
say i uploaded a youtube video it'll
give the title and a shortened link with
a beatbit.ly i think it is
so i'm just go ahead and click when will
actions be shared and it says uploads
will be posted to your connected
services after they have finished
processing so it's not going to go ahead
and shoot up a link to your twitter
followers before it's done processing
anything set to private will not be uh
will not will not be shared so if you
you upload a video set to private that
won't be posted to twitter if you um if
you're like me and you have your
comments ratings and favorites if you
have uh things like that on private i
happen to have ratings and comments on
private uh then they won't show up on
twitter so if you go to my account right
here and uh you can go down and look
under recent activity and i have like i
said all those things under privacy are
are not set to public
so anything like this you can also go to
auto share options and choose what you
want it to be shared with an activity
feed just uncheck anything you don't
want to be shared with twitter and go
ahead and uh
send that up and that that'll basically
be it you hit save changes and you are
done with your uh twitter to youtube
linking so i hope this tutorial helped
you guys link your youtube to your
twitter so now it'll be a lot easier uh
you might leave the house when you're
uploading a video but your followers
will always know when it's been done
processing and they can watch it
hopefully if it's uh if they're short on
time they can just catch it so anyway
thanks for watching this video i hope
you guys liked it and i guess i'll catch
you guys in the next video peace
you